Hey, everybody. Welcome to our
first November corrections of
the year. Very excited. I said
Joseph Gibbles. It's Joseph
Gibbles. So apologies to him
and his family. His fam his
family and him. Him and his
want to get it right. Casey's
also, you know, grammar Nazi.
Oh I bet you're not both.
I said Star Wars, it's Star
Wars. I thought both worked but
I guess I will defer to the
nerds. I thought in that galaxy
that the Ts and the Ps were
just sort of interchangeable. I
said Richard Attenborough. I
was told it's pronounced
written Richard Attenborough.
I've made it too much. Richard
Attenborough. And in New
England where I grew up it's we
say Richard Attenborough. We
say it derisively about people
who have weird pets. Kids got
four lizards and a boa
constrictor. Richard
Attenborough.
My sister is friends with his
My sister's friends with his
cousin. Been to his house. I
guess he freezes mice. Fridge
full of mice. Weirdo. Richard
Attenborough. Speaking of New
England, I've we've been
talking about, I don't want to
get into it, this feud. I
referred to my home state of
New Hampshire as an upside down
Vermont and the reality is
Vermont's an upside down New
Hampshire. New Hampshire joined
the union like almost three
years before Vermont. Like we
we did that shape first.
Probably waited. Wanted to make
sure the union had like an
organic section in their
grocery store. You're not
better than us.
We talked about Joe Manchin's
houseboat and we made the point
that it's a yacht. It's not
really a houseboat. She took a
picture of it. It's not how you
picture a houseboat and we also
said, houseboats don't have
cursive on the back, the name
of the boat. Multiple people
said, that's not cursive.
That's script. Cursive, the
letters have to connect and
that was just fancy script and
they said, but we don't blame
you because you don't teach
cursive anymore in schools. And
it's true. They barely I mean
this is the problem with
schools now. And when they do
teach kids cursives it it's
only to write mean things about
white people.
Cursive race training.
Can we show up that photo of
Lowe's that I criticized? I
gave our I said to our you know
we've had trouble with our
graphics department. I'm like
look at this. You have you know
aisle sixty1 and sixty-two on
one side and then aisle
seventeen on the other.
Obviously that's not how it
looks. Bunch of people wrote up
and said look I once I work at
Lowe's. That's how it looks.
Lot of people said I go to
And I know what you're thinking
that I'm some sort of I don't
know. Liberal elite who doesn't
go to home stores.
Talking about how everybody you
know was celebrating basically
the the news took a week off
reporting anything except for
the fact that Colin Jost passed
me as the update anchored host
of the most episodes of weekend
update and I said well you're
all throwing crowns at his feet
and someone said it's casting
crowns that's in the Bible it's
casting crowns I will admit I'm
not a a Bible reader two places
you would not find me grown up
sure in Lowe's. Um so I looked
it up because I wanted to see
if it was casting crowns or
throwing crowns. I looked it up
and it was a revelation. It was
in Revelation.
Um somebody said you know he
didn't actually pass you Colin
Jost because if you think about
it some of your weekend updates
you were a solo anchor whereas
all of his have been either
with Cecily or Chay so he
should really only get half
points for those whereas a lot
of yours were full points so if
you count it that way your way
ahead and I was very excited by
this theory that I was buying
into it and then I looked at
who wrote it and the name was
Mike Pillow fan. I was like it
was Mike Lindell. And I just
bought in and I realized now
like that's what Trump does. If
he's telling you something you
want to hear sounds like a
pretty sharp guy. We had a we
showed a photo of Mike Lindell
in Joker makeup and said why so
serious
the Joker makeup was Joaquin
Phoenix Joker not Heath Ledger
Joker and people you know comic
book fans are upset because
each Joker has sort of their
own iconic phrase Heath Ledger
was why so serious Jack
Nicholson was way to get a load
of me Jared Letto was you cut
all my scenes
I So, we talked about Gonzo and
his genitals. Here's how it
came up. There was a it was
based on the gift of the Magi
and there was a gift of the
Magi story in the 1978 Sesame
Street Christmas special I said
originally that it was a
Muppets Christmas special and
then I had to clarify that that
actually never aired because in
a lot of the shots you could
see Gonzo
and then someone said you know
he doesn't first of all why
would you even assume Gonzo has
one Gonzo's gender is never
established and that's very
fair but we did we do we do
have a picture of it now this
is obviously not for everyone
You know, if you don't want to
see a picture of Gonzo's penis,
Just look away now. Let's take
a look.
So it kind of makes sense.
Okay. I talked about eating
Necko wafers for Halloween and
a lot of people said Necko
wafers they don't make those
anymore they're discontinued to
that I would just say you don't
think there's some weirdos in
New York who bought a bunch of
Necko wafers a decade ago and
have just been slowly handing
them out you don't think people
are giving away old candy bars
in New York City you don't
think if you knock on Rudy
Giuliani's door he's not
going to give you a Reggie Bar
I said that if you Babaduke
which is a a horror movie an
Australian horror movie. I also
said it sounds like the slying
to Babaduke is to get super
drunk in your pants. And then
later in that closer look I
said someone would Babaduke
their pants. To which a person
said you already said
Babaduking mean your pants. So
to Babaduke your pants would be
to your pants your pants.
Sorry. Oh this isn't really
correction. This is just
something that's like coming
down the pipe that we're a
little worried about. We've
been talking a lot. Uh by the
time you see this the Jets will
have played on Thursday night
football. And we're very
worried that the Jets might be
good now. And if the Jets are
good now we we're going to shut
it down. They have a new
quarterback through for 400
yards last week against the
Bengals Mike White who I mean
with that and White Lotus what
a year
you showed a picture of Baby
Hitler can we show that baby
Hitler picture and then we had
a conversation a lot of people
said hey Hitler's eyes weren't
blue and then someone else said
actually they were blue and
people just think they're brown
because mostly you saw black
and white pictures of Hitler
and so people assumed they were
brown but he did have blue eyes
and there was a lot of back and
forth and then someone kind of
snuck in with a correct
Sometimes there's a very like
sometimes the jackals get so
specific that they miss a real
easy one and it was like days
later that someone said a baby
can't grow a mustache.
Can't argue with it. We talked
about how during the Trump era
our jokes jokes wrote
themselves and then I also
talked about how we had elves
that Shoemaker was very mean to
and people said what is it do
the jokes write themselves or
were the jokes written by what
happened was someone said who
wrote your jokes and I went
them selves
That's what happened.
It's funny to think we you know
we talked about the fact that
and I think while we got to
that point it's like you know
the elves and a shoemaker the
shoemaker are very very famous
fable and it it is funny to me
that like Shoemaker at some
point you had someone in your
life who was a shoemaker who
I'm sure like was like one size
fits all And you're like how
does that even work? You're
like nine. Look. She make her
half Italian, half German.
Which is why everyday at work I
feel like I'm fighting World
War two.
Um we had a photo of rats, a
rat with a six pack. Multiple
people told me based on rat's
muscles, they only have four
packs. Richard Attenborough. Uh
I sang the lyrics to a 10, 000
maniac song. I said these are
the days to remember. I got it
wrong. It's these are days to
remember. And then bae said
more like these are lyrics to
forget. And I had to take him
aside and say, you have to stop
pitching on corrections. I
don't think, I don't think you
see what we're trying to do
here.
We talked about John Steinbeck
and I did a a bit about him and
his editor and then a bunch of
people said his editor had a
name and there were a few
suggestions people had at his
editor and and so then I
started digging into it which
happens a lot. One of the joys
of corrections is you find out
things he didn't know and if
you can look at it, Steinbeck
articles and this is a true
story This happened. I'm not
allowed to say, this is a true
story that happened. People
don't like that. Oh, I almost
forgot one thing about the
elves. I talked about how
Shoemaker threw the elves out
the window and people said 30
Rock the Windows don't open.
You he couldn't throw an elve
out the window and it's true
they used to open all the way
but now they just open a little
bit but Shoemaker, it's enough
for Shoemaker to really
muscle an elf out.
Steinbeck. It turns out that
1930 using a pen name. John
Steinbeck, Nobel winner,
Pulitzer winner, wrote a
werewolf murder mystery called
Murder at Full Moon that the
Steinbeck Estate will not
publish because he did not
publish it in his there's a
Steinbeck imagine this poor man
who just wanted to write fun
things. Wrote a werewolf murder
mystery. Brought it to his
editor and he said it was like
people don't like stuff like
this. Give me something on the
dust bowl.
Write me something about a dumb
guy who doesn't know his own
strength.
I got something called travels
with Charlie. That sounds like
it stinks.
I only read Travels with
Charlie in school. Base, did
you read Travels with Charlie?
I think it stinks. When I was a
kid, I didn't like it. I maybe
I'll give it another chance. I
won't. I feel bad. If you are a
jackal and you feel like I
should give travels with
Charlie another try but then if
you're also like, you know what
else is good? A separate piece
then no. Okay. Mugs we had a
couple of mugs last week and it
was it was our Halloween week
and I wanted to see if you guys
knew what they were so this one
right here so that that's a
jack-o-lantern and then a bunch
of people said yeah but it
shouldn't be black there should
be like it should be like
yellow from the candle and to
that I'd only say I made it
black for a reason because
jackals have no light inside
them and this this is the deep
cut right here I'm really proud
of this so this is a this is a
jackal bring this is a jackal
intern
No. And Tara from graphics made
that and a lot of people said
is this our is our close up
over there? Let me get a close
up of this. So, a lot of people
said there's a problem. That's
not that's not a jackal that's
a hyena. And so I went down to
graphics. I went down to Tara
and Tara's very good at her job
but everybody who works here
will attest mean.
Mean person and
I said a lot of the jackals are
saying that you did not
represent them on that mug that
that is a hyena and I said do
you have anything to say to
them and she said did you show
them the other side of the mug?
And I said I didn't even
realize there was anything on
the other side of the mug. So
here you go. This is from Tara
and Graphics everybody.
See me next week.